Okay,
here's what I think we should do to the guy who killed Blake and Riley.
If you don't know, he was found guilty,
and he'll probably spend the rest of his life in a tax rented prison.
He'll get food, clothing,
shelter, healthcare,
all those things. But if we lived in a society,
in a country where justice was really important,
here's what we would do. Anytime someone committed a crime like this,
like something really extreme,
something really horrible,
we would take them and put them on an island somewhere.
I'm thinking somewhere just off the east coast.
Doesn't have to be a big island,
but it needs to be big enough to fit several of these people.
And again, this island is reserved for the worst of the worst
people who life in prison is too nice,
but also, like capital punishment is also too nice.
And you don't really know what to do with them.
So you take them, you drop them off on this island.
They're basically allowed to just wander around,
survive, trying to find food.
Maybe if you give them, like,
a tent or something. And then rich people or anyone who can afford it
can pay to go to this island and to do some big game hunting.
It's a free for all. All the ticket sales, food,
the drinks, all that money goes to the victims families.
Win win, win.
Really think it could be kind of a bipartisan thing,
because I feel like we all agree that the prison sentences,
the things that we're doing,
like, it's just not satisfying.
There's no justice. It's just kind of.
I think my idea would actually work out really well.
I maybe will type it out,
maybe make a Powerpoint and email it to the DOJ.
A lot of us worry about, like,
where our next meals are gonna come from
or paying for healthcare and stuff.
This guy doesn't even have to worry about.
He'll never have to worry about for the rest of his life.
It's just so messed up. I'm sorry.
Anyway, that's my idea, though.
Let me know what you think.